president obama is coming back to the
political scene the fire and the fury
and the furious all of it will be
discussed plus we talked about the
mailbag into the mailbag day you can
part of it i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show all right so to give
you the latest on North Korea in just a
moment plus the Democrats basically
taking sides with North Korea over
Donald Trump if forced to make a
decision
some Trump staffing issues and from
Russia stuff plus we're going to do a
fulsome mailbag today but before we get
to any of that I first want to say thank
you to our sponsors over at vertical so
right now things seem a little uncertain
do you wake up in the morning wondering
whether you will survive a nuclear
attack if so you may want to consider
what would happen to the markets if in
fact the world situation grows more
volatile rather than less the stock
market took a dump yesterday to the tune
about two hundred points this is why you
should have at least some of your assets
in precious metals and that's why I
trust the folks at Birch gold with my
precious metals investment birchgold.com
/ Ben gets you a comprehensive 16 page
kit revealing how gold and silver can
protect your savings how you can legally
move your IRA or 401k out of stocks and
bonds into a precious metals IRA right
now thanks to a little-known IRS tax law
you can do that without real tax
consequences which is pretty awesome
Birch gold group has an A+ rating from
the Better Business Bureau countless
five-star reviews the folks I trust ask
all your questions and then once you get
your answers take some of your assets
and put them in precious metals
birchgold.com / Ben that is
birchgold.com / Ben let them know that
we sent you okay so the hubbub over
North Korea continues to unfold and
evolve so president Trump I do love the
fact that for president from not only
does he never back down he always
doubles down like everything is a double
down for for president Trump if you ever
played poker with him you would always
want to go all-in and this is sort of
the problem the reason being that half
the time he's bluffing and half the time
he's not and you really don't know when
he's bluffing and when he's not but you
have a pretty good indication that he's
bluffing sometimes because he can never
get out of a hand he never just puts it
down and says okay walk away from this
hand everything has to be double down on
so you remember a couple of days ago
Trump said about North Korea that if
North Korea were to continue to threaten
then he would unleash the fire and the
fury and frankly the power remember all
of this fire furious furious frankly
power Mad Max fury road unbelievable
Draconis and so everyone went nuts the
dead the left just thought this is
insane he's going to burn everyone alive
and I was saying calm down everyone
that's not going to happen there are
negotiations happening behind the scenes
Trump tweet stuff because that's what
Trump does and even the North Koreans
know better than to fire a nuclear
missile just because Trump is mouthing
off they know enough to know that should
they actually try something we would
finish them they would be done so this
morning Trump tweeted out military
solutions are now fully in place locked
and loaded should North Korea act
unwisely
hopefully Kim jong-un will find another
path again every so it's an escalation a
dramatic escalation the rhetoric is
escalating the activity is not so we are
doing the same fly of flyovers of North
Korea that we've always been doing we've
been doing the same joint naval
exercises with the Japanese and with the
South Koreans rather with the South
Koreans that we've always been doing
nothing has really changed along those
scores so the idea that Trump is
dramatically escalating the situation
it's just not true but his rhetoric is
constantly escalating because Trump get
too high off of his own fumes when it
comes to the level of his rhetoric I
mean this is why he has people
apparently bring him folders filled with
pictures of him looking powerful so
yesterday he's asked about the fire and
the fury and the fury Oh said phenomenal
phenomenal fury and he was and he says
not only was I right then I'm going to
double down it's not even big enough I
think we have to go even bigger with the
rhetoric and frankly the people that
were questioning that statement was it
too tough
maybe it wasn't tough enough they've
been doing this in our country for a
long time for many years and it's about
time that somebody stuck up for the
people of this country and for the
people of other countries so if anything
maybe that statement wasn't tough enough
and we're backed by a hundred percent by
our military we're backed by everybody
and were backed by many other leaders
and I noticed that many senators and
others today came out very much in favor
of what I said but if anything that
statement may not be tough enough
I love that it keeps saying that the
statement it may not be tough enough he
does it stirring the campaign a lot also
any time he was asked about something he
would say there's some people who saying
I didn't go far enough maybe I should
have gone farther I should have talked
about the ferocity frenzy furor I should
know it's the fierceness and the flare
up of the doors should talk about all of
those things just for alliterative
purposes alliteration is where the first
letter is the same of other words in the
sound is the same yes beep um okay so is
all of this helpful you know I thought
honestly I don't think it's that bad I
don't think it hurts I don't think it's
the end of the world I don't think we're
going to get in the nuclear war because
Trump is doing any of this stuff and all
the media members attempting to push you
into feeling this way have an agenda as
we discussed yesterday Trump said listen
this is not a dare you know I'm not
daring North Korea to do anything I'm
just stating if they do something then
we'll finish them let's see what he does
with Guam he does something in Guam it
will be an event the likes of which
nobody's seen before what will happen in
North Korea I mean you'll see you'll see
and he'll see he will see is that a dare
it's a statement has nothing to do with
their that's a statement he's not going
to go around threatening Guam and he's
not going to threaten the United States
and he's not going to threaten Japan and
he's not going to threaten South Korea
no that's not a dare as you say that is
a statement of fact so what's the actual
likelihood of anything happening here
very low because here's the reality the
Kim jong-un regime is mainly interested
in self-preservation it's a stable
regime because they don't care if they
continue killing their own people and
oppressing their own people for decades
now that they've been doing it now for
60 odd years so nothing really changes
there all they care about is maintaining
their own power and that means the last
thing they're going to do is launch a
nuclear weapon and Guam or launch a
nuclear weapon at the United States what
they could do is is act bellicose in an
attempt to gain concessions from the
world because this is what they've been
doing for the past couple of decades
if Trump shows that they're not going to
get any concessions for this then in
fact we're going to ratchet up sanctions
every time they do this then maybe
they'll cut out even that now is that
the greatest possible outcome no I mean
it would be great if the Kim family
would just all drop dead immediately
that would be the best possible outcome
for the world
the best possible outcome for the North
Korean people who don't deserve this
monstrosity that's been thrust upon them
for the better part of half a century
but that said are we at the verge of
nuclear war no we're not now what is the
danger of them having a weapon like this
there are really two dangers of the
North Koreans having an intercontinental
ballistic missile with an atomic tip
okay there are two basic threats one
threat is that all of the of neighboring
all the neighboring countries are then
one say okay well if they have a nuclear
weapon we should have a nuclear weapon
like South Korea will say listen we
can't be living under the nuclear
umbrella of the North Koreans we should
have the capacity to say to them if you
fire anything at us we will nuke you
right if you're if you find a
conventional weaponry at us and then
threaten us with your nuclear weapon we
will finish you right so the South
Koreans might develop their own nuclear
weapon Japan which has been non-nuclear
they may develop their own nuclear
weapon in order to deter the the North
Koreans and so you could see widespread
proliferation around the world and John
Pat Horace is making this point in his
commentary podcast and I think it's
right that we've spent again every
basically every waking moment since 1945
in the use of the a bomb in Hiroshima
and Nagasaki we've been spending all
that time trying to prevent the
proliferation of nuclear weapons there
been a number of states like South
Africa that have gone non-nuclear Libya
was giving up its nuclear ambitions you
know there have been a number of states
that have decided not to go nuclear
specifically because they felt like
there is a global taboo against the use
of nuclear weapons but now you're seeing
proliferation spread Pakistan is
proliferating Iran is going to
proliferate thanks to the Obama
administration Saudi Arabia in response
could proliferate thanks to the Obama
administration you could see Turkey and
Jordan proliferate you could see a
widespread development of nuclear
weapons and that would be very dangerous
because again all it takes is one
mistake for things to go boom it's one
thing when you're talking about two
regimes when the years half of the USSR
in the United States and we were
basically the only nuclear powers then
you know that that was hard enough to
keep us from going boom right we had
things like the Cuban Missile Crisis
during the six-day war in 1967 there
were serious nuclear threats that were
issued by the Soviets with regard to the
Middle East so it was very tenuous even
between two powers one of which was good
one which was evil but both of which
were rational in terms of
self-preservation what happens if you
have a regime that is that is really
tenuous and that feels that it's only
method of defense is a nuclear weapon
and everybody else is proliferating so
that's danger number one danger number
two is you can see a world in which the
North Koreans start to pursue more
aggressive action attempt to ratchet up
pressure on the world to give them
concessions and so they start destroying
South Korean boats right they started
threatening GEB Japan firing missiles at
Japan every so often and basically
saying listen what you're going to do
about it your taxes will move somebody
using that as their deterrent not in
order to calm the waters but in order to
royal waters that's the danger in North
Korea but is the danger immediate
nuclear war no I don't think the danger
is immediate nuclear war
so everybody ought to you know stop
thinking that their Linda Hamilton in
Terminator 2 where they're grabbing a
chain-link fence is the blast wave hits
them and rips their skin away from their
body I don't think that's what's about
to happen here but by the same token the
military option certainly should not be
off the table because things are only
going to get worse not better with North
Korea I think everybody who's assuming
that this regime is just going to
magically collapse because it Soviet
Union collapsed because Mikhail
Gorbachev made a vast miscalculation
with regard to modernization he felt
okay if we modernize if we open our
doors a little bit if we do glass not
the Soviet Union will survive instead
everyone who could opt out of the system
opted out of the system the Kim regime
is not going to make the same mistake
they're going to keep this thing locked
down as long as humanly possible Kim
Jong moon is a very young man and that
means that he is going to be around for
quite a while unfortunately barring some
sort of miracle that takes him out you
know I hate to pray for a God to kill
people but if God's going to take
somebody let him take him jung-hoon a
guy's a piece of human debris and the
entire family needs to be deposed but he
is easy in my age right he's 33 years
old in fact he was born a week before I
was so it's you know he's a young guy
could be around for another 50 years so
the idea that this is on the verge of
collapse is just not true and that's why
it's such a dangerous situation now
because the dangerous situation you
would assume that the Democrats should
for just a second put aside their animus
for President Trump and start talking
instead about supporting a basic
American stance on this which is that
North Korea has to calm that stuff down
or we're going to be forced into taking
action in North Korea the negotiations
should be taking place that when Trump
says things he does have the credible
threat of force behind him and instead
Democrats have decided it's more
important to shame president Trump talk
about that in just a second but first I
want to say thank you to our sponsors
over the u.s. ECA so in
it is an amazing story guy named Devin
Hopkins woke during the night to a
stranger banging on the side of his
house trying to break into his basement
he was fearing for his life so Devin got
a gun confronted the burglar aimed low
to shoot a man in the leg
now path forward a year he's not being
charged with aggravated assault and
careless use of a firearm and apparently
he was sentenced in July 2016 for
defending himself in his own home the
burglar has yet to be charged the world
is not fair just because you're
defending yourself in your own home just
because you're defending yourself from
home intruders that doesn't mean that
the police aren't going to come and
arrest you and you might not be
prosecuted and that's why you need to
work with the u.s. CCA the u.s. CCA
wants to protect hardworking Americans
who are trying to defend themselves and
their families that's why they're there
to educate train ensure responsibly
armed citizens before during and after a
self-defense incident no one should go
through the aftermath of a self-defense
incident alone and the u.s. CCA is
making sure you can defend yourself
they're giving a gun away every day to
show appreciation and support for our
Second Amendment rights for information
about their life-saving coverage visit
defend my family now calm today let's
defend my family now calm again they'll
make sure that if you that you're
educated for when to pull the trigger
how to pull the trigger you can go - to
defend my family now calm right now and
register for the possibility of winning
a gun they're giving away a gun every
day you can do all of that plus if God
forbid you have to use your gun in
self-defense scenario then they will
help you ensure that you are legally
covered and you don't either go bankrupt
or spend the rest of your life in court
or jail that's what the u.s. CCA is
there for so go over and check out
defend my family now calm okay so
naturally Trump is saying all this stuff
and the media is trying to make it out
that he's a crazy person who's going to
get us into a nuclear war not happening
and the Democrats are trying to suggest
that Trump is actually the bad guy so
the democratic representative named Juan
Castro he is is is this who being cast
for one I know that they won and who
lien are twins
so this one is Joaquin sorry Joaquin
Castro so who lien and Joaquin are
brothers and Joaquin was arguing that
North Korea is just getting more more
threatening because of Trump not because
they threatened and they've been
threatening consistently for my entire
lifetime but because of Trump I mean
this is just this is working in bad
faith for Democrats it really is here is
here's Castro well the first thing
is that I think some of these threats
have been made because the president has
also made his own threats and so that's
why I'm saying that we need to allow
diplomacy a chance to work instead of
going tit-for-tat
with 32 year old dictator in North Korea
okay
diplomacy is working in fact there the
reports today that diplomacy is is
moving forward that the Trump
administration has had contact for
months with the North Koreans and that
we are moving toward some sort of
defusing of the situation but the idea
that you're going to go on national TV
and you're going to undercut the
credible use of military force with
regard to South Korea with regard to
North Korea is very dangerous notion
Maxine Waters doing the same thing again
Maxine Waters has been proclaiming for
months the Trump will be impeached or
Trump or plots or something will happen
that will get Trump out of there through
some democratic created miracle she says
that Trump is bluffing okay again this
is bad stuff you never want to say that
the President of the United States is
bluffing
when Obama drew his red line in Syria
there were those of us who said it's
stupid to draw the red line if you're
bluffing but it was not a good thing if
we were out there saying he's definitely
bluffing you don't want to you don't
want to show enemy regimes that you
think the President of the United States
is full of it because it means that
they're credible use of threat that
they're credible threat for use of force
is gone how do you deter if people think
that you're completely full of it here's
maximum water however whose top priority
is not preventing North Korea from
getting aggressive her top priority is
instead trying to humiliate president
Trump I believe that North Korea is
interesting threat to the United States
but I think there are some things that
they want from us and we have to find
out whether or not we can work with them
on the things that they're asking for
and so this is something that we should
be very concerned about but this is not
the time to go bluffing and threatening
it's a good time for diplomacy okay so
you know whenever Democrats say it's
time for diplomacy diplomacy involves
the credible threat of use of force and
that's half of diplomacy the whole idea
of diplomacy is supposedly the iron fist
inside the velvet glove and you either
get the velvet glove or you get the fist
if there is no credible threat then why
engage in diplomacy in the first place I
mean if the
Koreans know we're not going to do
anything then why wouldn't they just
continue to develop their nuclear
weapons and threaten whomever they want
and fire nuclear weapons at whomever
they choose there has to be a credible
threat of force Democrat Street
diplomacy it's a pet peeve of mine they
treat diplomacy as those diplomacy is an
actual is an actual policy instead of
diplomacy being a strategy toward the
achievements of policy there is a
difference okay a policy is something
that you are attempting to forward
obviously you would prefer to promise
you divorce if they achieve the same end
but if they don't achieve the same end
then you have to determine is diplomacy
better or a force better diplomacy is a
strategy it's like you know I'm going to
fight with my wife right I have a couple
of strategies as to how I can defuse the
situation okay the goal is not the
strategy the goal is to defuse the
situation maybe to defuse the situation
I need to give her space maybe to defuse
the situation I need to hug her and talk
but those are strategies towards
defusing the situation the goal of the
situation isn't for me to have alone
time we go over the situation isn't for
me to grab a hug you know Maxine Waters
and Democrats they treat diplomacy as
though the goal of the situation is to
talk with North Korea warrants to spend
their time talking with North Korea the
purpose of talking with North Korea is
to achieve some sort of settlement where
we're not on the verge of nuclear war
every five seconds with a nutcase who
lives there that's the purpose of all of
this you know one of my pet peeves here
is also Ben Rhodes who just needs to go
away and shut up Ben Rhodes the the
idiot national security adviser under
President Obama his great national
security experience before that had been
being a failed novelist with with he'd
written some half a novel that was never
published and it's really he is the
author of the egregious and horrifying
Iran deal and he's tweeting out about
this stuff he should shut up because the
bottom line is that we're going to be in
the same situation with Iran in about
five minutes here because he signed a
nuclear deal with the Iranians that
allows them to pursue a nuclear weapon
the minute they say they have developed
a nuclear weapon then all of a sudden
we're going to get always because Trump
undermines a nuclear deal that's why all
this happened no the reason this
happened is because Iran was pursuing a
nuclear weapon the Obama administration
chose to ignore it in favor of trying to
make overtures one of the most evil
regimes on the planet exactly is the
Clinton administration did during the
1990s you know Ben Rhodes
he said he's tweeting out now Trump
turned to national security was
inevitable given domestic daily errs and
constraints but this week doesn't bode
well for next three
so now this is a distraction remind me
again who was it who was threatening
Guam oh yeah I was the North Koreans
remind me who was it who was reported to
have built a nuclear weapon that can fit
on the tip of an ICBM that's right it
was North Korea but the Democratic Trump
so much that everything everything is
Trump's fault
and then you've got and then you've got
Ben Rhodes tweeting about how it is how
we can't back out of the Iran deal
because if we back out of the Iran deal
then it's just terrible he says this is
a key point
any chance of a deal with North Korea
goes out the window if Trump cancels a
nuclear deal that Iran is complying with
then maybe you shouldn't have signed a
bad nuclear deal with Iran handing them
that's handing them they the store
opening the grocery store the Democrats
keep signing bad deals and then they're
shocked when everybody takes advantage
of the bad deals that is far more of a
problem than people trying to enforce
deals and trying to ensure that that
places don't go nuclear and threaten
others it's really quite amazing I mean
that the delusion of the Democrats is
insane he says that you know they're
ripping on Trump because it's sweet
about military solutions and locked and
loaded he says are we coordinating with
our allies listen I am sure that our
military is coordinating with our allies
Trump says stuff everybody knows Trump
says stuff so I'm highly doubtful that
were in the midst of a nuclear war here
but this is what Democrats want you to
believe so that you're scared of
President Trump okay meanwhile there's
been some hubbub about Trump staffing
decisions with regard to national
security and this is indeed a problem
you want to present a united face when
it comes to your national security team
Trump's governing by chaos is not useful
when it comes to national security so
you've got open battles now between
Steve Bannon from chief strategist and
HR McMaster Trump's national security
adviser McMaster has ousted a bunch of
Bandhan loyalists inside the
administration some of whom should have
been ousted some of whom probably should
not have been ousted McMaster is an
expert on on counterinsurgency his
perspective on Afghanistan is apparently
one of the things at issue with with
Stephen and bandages wants to get out of
Afghanistan my master is saying guys al
Qaeda is still there if we get out of
there there will be another terrorist
attack we ought to be staffing up not
staffing down in Afghanistan
Dannan is arguing the reverse that fight
is causing Bannon to feel marginalized
and lash out at McMaster there's some
ancillary
dr. McMaster McMaster is not
particularly pro-israel which i think is
a problem obviously but Trump is the
president and if he can check McMaster
on Israel and then listen to his advice
on Afghanistan that seems to me probably
a better strategy Trump has been forced
to come out yesterday for example and
say that he has confidence in his own
national security adviser this does not
provide the sort of face to the world
that you want what you want when it
comes to foreign policy is United Front
where people know that whatever you say
is credible that there are not arguments
among your members of your
administration publicly you don't want
members of your administration arguing
with each other that creates confusion
and it leads America's enemies to sit
around thinking okay what do they really
think what do they really want so here
is Trump being forced to to testify to
the greatness of McMaster you have all
confidence and your national security
advice
yes I do general McMaster absolutely
he's our friend he's my friend and he's
a very talented man I like him and I
respect him okay so you know he's
sticking with me master for now the the
right is very upset with McMaster
because of all the purges of the a lot
of the Mandan people and the feeling
that a master is more of a traditional
defense guy who's willing to work with
Obama holdovers all of that is Trump's
call all of its Trump's call I keep
hearing from people you got to trust
Trump fine trust from it is called time
for him to get his poop in order the
same thing is happening with regard to
Sebastian Gorka Sebastian Gorka is one
of the national security advisors a
foreign policy adviser to President
Trump it seems like his main job is to
go on TV and say stuff that Trump likes
Sebastian Gork I've met him I think once
it seems like a nice guy
I think he's pretty knowledgeable about
world events but you know he and Rex
Tillerson Trump Stone Secretary of State
are going at it because Tillerson is
saying don't worry about the
militaristic rhetoric we're working on
something and Gorkhas out there saying
Tillerson did say he doesn't get to talk
about what defense department is doing
and so now Gorka is under fire for going
to war with Tillerson sebastian you know
this is going to be all over the papers
and whether you had the exact meaning
that people have now interpreted it it
looks like to some people it looks like
forget backstabbing that you front stab
the Secretary of State and you know
people look at that say who was he to
admonish any process that the Secretary
of State would take
he's handpicked by the president I was
admonishing the journalist of the fake
news industrial complex who are forcing
our chief diplomat into a position where
they are demanding he makes the military
case for action when that is not the
Mandate of this Secretary of State
that's why we have a department defense
if a journalist doesn't know the
difference that's when we so Gorica
tries to turn on the media but again
Trump needs to get his team under
control you'd hope that John Kelly would
help him with this but obviously Kelly
is not able to get everything under
control as of yet and that is that is
not a good thing okay
so before we get to things I like and
things I hate that I want to spend some
ample time on the mailbag first I want
to say thank you to our sponsors over at
policy genius so right now if you don't
have a life insurance policy you are
making a very large mistake you should
have a life insurance policy no matter
how young you are no matter how old the
bottom line is you don't want to die and
leave your family in the large policy
genius comm is the place you can go to
learn about life insurance compare
quotes from America's top providers and
save up to 40% on your policy they've
placed over five billion dollars in life
insurance
in fact most Americans think life
insurance costs two to three times more
than it actually does you can save a lot
of money by going to policy genius.com
and they have a licensed team of experts
willing to talk you through it no call
waiting you don't have to worry about
going through some sort of computerized
system yet actual customer service
you've been putting all of this off you
need to go to policy genius.com
today make sure that you're getting the
best life insurance he'll be possibly
can policy genius.com today again you
can save up to 40% just by comparing
policies shopping around is the way to
get life insurance anyway a policy
genius does all the legwork for you the
quotes are free no sales pressure no
hassle policy genius.com go check it out
make sure that your family is is covered
in case something bad should happen to
new gives you a certain level of peace
of mind that is certainly very
worthwhile okay so before we get to
things I like and things I hate in the
mailbag first we have to say goodbye to
you over on Facebook and the visuals of
YouTube so if you do not know and you
just listen to us online we are in a
visual show not just an audio show if
you want to watch us you want to watch
this show unfold in real-time watch the
magic happen
enjoy it's going part of the mailbag
we have a mail bag and you can be part
of a live mail bag right now today if
you go over and subscribe to daily
wire.com for just $9.99 a month you get
the subscription to not only the show
but andrew Clavin shall see that live
the Michael Noel's show which is surging
up the iTunes charts for some
godforsaken reason you can check that
out as well it's actually quite good you
can give that a listen and a watch and
you can part of Michael's mailbag he
also bears when he wears glasses
striking resemblance to Rachel Maddow
real it really incredible but you can
check that out as well for $9.99 a month
and and you can also get the annual
subscription for $99 a year for that you
not only get all of the above mentioned
things but you also get this the most
magnificent two tumblers this left this
year's hot or cold I drink out of it
every day my lips I only allow my lips
to touch the finest things and this
right here like my wife and this right
here is one of the finest things in life
this left this year's hot or cold
tumbler it is just incredible it is
magnificent you will enjoy every time
you hold it you'll feel the power surge
through you it's like the power of the
Ring except not evil check it out
leftist airs hot or cold tumbler for a
$99 annual fee and become part of our
team and join the mailbag so you can ask
them questions right now and make your
life complete so make sure you subscribe
also we are for the entire week we have
been number one news and politics
podcast in the country we are number two
to Oprah
folks a little disappointed not in you I
think that I think iTunes is screwing
with us to be honest with you you know
you look at look at look at Oprah's
ratings and she's at like two-and-a-half
stars or five stars with 8,000 refused
at this point but we are number two to
Oprah Oprah must be defeated must be
defeated I understand that she may
release B's on her audience I've seen
that from the interwebs but you should
we should help us anyway go over and
subscribe leave a sort of view we always
appreciate it we are the largest
conservative and at news and politics
podcasts in America
[Music]
okay so time for some things I like in
things I hate because I would like to
leave ample time for the mailbag today
so we'll go right to things I like
so today's thing is I like another book
on North Korea I think people should be
educated about this state the book is
called the impossible state by Victor
cha and it is a history of North Korea
it looks back at what it was it looks
forward to what's going to happen there
on it talks about its level of stability
what comes after if the Kim family
should basically lose power whether
there is in fact some sort of internal
turmoil it's very difficult to tell
North Korea sort of a black box and so
they're reporting on North Korea tends
to be a little bit haphazard because
they don't allow foreign journalists in
but this book is quite a good look at
North Korea how it operates and why it
has the problems that it has the
impossible State North Korea past and
future by a Victor cha you can go check
that out okay other things that I like
so
Barack Obama is coming back so this is
exciting he's going to campaign for the
Democrats I could not be more excited
about this Democrats are so screwed that
they are trying to bring back the ghost
of Christmas past so bringing back the
president who awesome a thousand seats
in state houses across the country
twelve governorships ten in Senate seats
63 House seats that's the guy that they
are trying to restore to the leadership
of the Democratic Party the guy who
created a coalition so fragile that even
Hillary Clinton couldn't mobilize it in
her own favor to defeat a reality TV TV
game show host and Obama is back
apparently he's going to help them
fundraise hahaha the Democrats are have
raised apparently half the funding that
Republicans have since the election
cycle which is amazing
and he is apparently also going to help
the politicians out by speaking that is
not going to work for them so
congratulations to Democrats you have
hit on yet again one of the world's
worst strategies so that is just
excellent other news that other news
that I like it's not really news that I
like but I do like when reality when
reality takes him so here is the piece
of news by Amanda prestigio KOMO she is
one of the our favorite writers over at
say Lee Weyer a woman who enlisted to
become the first ever female Navy SEAL
quit after one week of training one week
of training
to the report from the Washington
Examiner the unidentified female
candidate dropped out in early August
during a three week course in San Diego
that began July 24th it was the first
assessment of potential seal officers
before they can be sent on to more
grueling courses according to the
website which cited multiple Naval
Special Warfare command sources so
before January 2016 women were not
allowed in military combat roles there
were no female applicants in the 18
months since that historic change until
July which is when this woman enlisted
she lasted for one week she lasted from
one week made so the fact that that that
she signed up listen anybody who signs
up is doing more than I have so I can't
criticize them on that basis but the
stupidity of a left that suggests that
women are exactly the same as men in
every way is demonstrated every single
day by reality by the way this is one of
the reasons I think this movie atomic
Grande is failing we were discussing
this before the show Mathis and Austin
Austin saw the movie he thinks it's
really good I haven't seen yet so I
really have no opinion on the quality of
the film apparently it has a 20-minute
fight sequence that's really amazing I
have a general problem with female fight
sequences where you get one woman
beating up guys who are 200 pounds which
is 105 pounds soaking wet beating the
crap out of guys who are 200 pounds is a
no-no in boxing we have weight classes
right if there's a 10 pound difference
between two boxers they're in different
weight classes you think that doesn't
apply to a 75 80 pound difference
between men and women like come on gang
come on so that I think that's one of
the reasons why the female action star
genre hasn't been doing particularly
well there been a bunch of movies that
have come out recently with the female
action star and they just don't work
that well typically because the
suspension of disbelief to watch a some
beautiful woman the size of my wife
throw around some 6 foot 3 dude who's
who weighs 240 pounds it requires a
certain suspension of disbelief I think
also the marketing for that film it
seemed to make a lot of the lesbian
relationship in the film and I think
that that's a mistake for the marketers
not just because people are some people
are put off by that but also because it
is this is a question I asked Austin I
asked in the film is there a reason the
Charlie's Tehran's character had to be a
woman instead of a man is there anything
about her character in the film that
makes her necessarily female in any in
any real way other than the package
she's a female and often
said no right she's seducing a woman in
the same way that James Bond would
seduce a woman so what is the what is
the relevance of her being woman if
she's a female action star but she's
basically just - dude who's a lady then
what have you gained from this like the
best written female action stars think
of Terminator - Linda Hamilton's
character is really well written because
her entire motivating feature is trying
to care for her child trying to make
sure that John is safe right that's the
entire motivation of her character if
you think of other great action movies
where a woman is put in a position of
peril often she's given a motivation
that is more typically feminine than you
know basically she could be James Bond
and I think that's a good thing I think
that people that there's something that
doesn't ring authentic about women who
just could be men on-screen or men who
could just be women on-screen you know
that men and women are different and we
pick up on that and films lack
authenticity when they don't when they
don't play into that I think so that's
not sexism that's just the reality of
men and women being different which I
understand is something we're not
allowed to talk about anymore I get all
of that okay
so other things okay so you know let's
do some things that I hate so I think
the president Trump needs to shut up
about Russia and the reason I think he
needs to shut up about Russia every time
he opens his mouth he just gives fodder
to the Democratic side now I still see
no evidence that Trump colluded with
Russia in this election cycle I see
evidence that his son Donald from jr.
attempted to collude with Russia but
that is not evidence of collusion the
person who is most closely tied with
Russia in the Trump campaign was poem
Anna for Paul Manafort was his chief
campaign staff he was the head of his
campaign for three months and he was
rated by the FBI apparently in the last
couple of months Trump was asked about
Manta Ford in the raid on him by the FBI
and here was Trump's and here was
Trump's statement to do that early in
the morning whether or not it was
appropriate you'd have to ask them I've
always found Paul Manafort to be a very
decent man and he's like a lot of other
people probably makes consultant fees
from all over the place who knows I
don't know but I thought that was a very
pretty tough stuff mr. president to wake
him up perhaps his family was there I
think that's pretty tough stuff okay the
reason that he should not say stuff like
this is because literally a week and a
half ago he was on tape talking to
police officers and saying when there is
a criminal
don't put your hand on the top of their
head if you have to rough them up a
little bit go ahead right now he's
talking about its really tough stuff
that Paul Manafort got woken up in the
middle of the night it's not a good look
okay not a good look
like that's not the problem here what he
should say is if he thinks metaphors
innocent he should say poor man afford
is innocent if he doesn't think he's
innocent shut up
but doing this whole he's a victim of
the system routine it just doesn't wash
and especially doesn't help that every
time Russia does something bad Trump
seems to feel the need to defend them in
some weird way so Vladimir Putin kicked
out 755 diplomats out of the US Embassy
in in Moscow apparently and here was
Trump's response to that no I want to
thank him because we're trying to cut
down a zero and as far as I'm concerned
I'm very thankful that he let go of a
large number of people because now we
have a smaller payroll there's no real
reason for them to go back so I greatly
appreciate the fact that they've been
able to cut our payroll for the United
States it will save a lot of money sort
of half joking there but I'm not sure
what that joke is supposed to mean
considering that all of these people are
still employed by the excited state so
it's not really true
shouldn't he say you know that's
inappropriate like they're a bunch of
people who just were kicked out of their
homes out of their living quarters
kicked out of the country shouldn't get
some points say that's bad wait I'm
sorry they saving us a lot of money
first of all is not even technically
true and second of all time to good
jokes I'm not sure what exactly he's
trying to accomplish with all of that
okay other things that I hate
Kathleen rice is a is a Congress
Democratic congresswoman she's very
angry because the NRA and Dana lash have
kind of series of the ads the ads are
very kind of tough in tone and tenor
they're not my favorite ads I love Dana
dan is wonderful I don't think this is a
dinner I don't mean as the best use of
data I think Dan is a wonderfully
charming person a very warm and inviting
personality and I think the ads have
become very kind of growly so they're
not my favorite thing in the world but
this is insane okay so Kathleen writes
is democratic representative she says
I'm just going to say it okay first of
all on Twitter whenever and in life
whenever you say I'm just going to say
it it's usually followed by something
you really should have thought more
about saying correct because I'm just
going to say it NRA and Dana lash are
quickly becoming domestic security
threats under President Trump we can't
ignore that the Messick's
security threats are you crazy I mean
the answer is yes you are crazy I mean
that's a crazy statement domestic
security threats are domestic security
threat when you suggest that Americans
ought to be armed in case of in case of
violence that Americans ought to be arms
in order to protect themselves from home
invasion like exercising their second
Amendment right that's what the NRA is
for and when Dana lash points out that
it's a threatening world out there their
domestic security threat no wonder
Republicans say the Democrats are
fascists when they issue stuff like this
once you label someone a domestic
security threat that leads to a
justification for shutting them down
that's utterly utterly not okay final
thing that I hate then we'll do some
mail back so final thing that I hate
here is ABC chief political analyst
again in Matthew Dowd he's reached out
dumb stuff about religion all the time
he used to be a bush 2004 campaign chief
strategist about a month ago he tweeted
out that he was Catholic and he said
being Christian is a state of being
practicing lourve some of the most
Christian folks I know in life are
atheists and every Christian went away
what a way to hold up a second is what
like being a nice person being a
Christian are not identical right
they're not quite the same thing some of
the most Christian people that he knows
are not atheists because like I'm a very
nice person to my employees despite me
making fun of them a lot
I'm very nice guy with my family I'm
generally a nice person tries to go on
my way for others I am NOT a Christian I
am a Jew right I mean like there are
certain set of beliefs you have to
engage in okay that wasn't even the
worst so yesterday he tweets out quote a
fundamentalist radical Christian is just
as misguided and frightening as a
fundamentalist radical Muslim no
difference um no okay if I see a guy in
the park shouting Jesus Saves he just
runs into the park holding a briefcase
he shouts Jesus Saves I think to myself
okay you know what I'm gonna like
probably you know like shy away from him
but I'm not really that afraid that
maybe he's willing to blow himself up
however if he runs into the park
carrying the briefcase and he shouts
Allahu Akbar then my reaction will be
slightly different and that's for a
reason that's because the vast majority
of bombings worldwide vast majority of
terrorist bombings worldwide are being
carried out by radical Muslim
fundamentalists
okay tens of thousands of people dead
every year thanks to radical Muslim
fundamentalism
twenty four percent of Americans believe
that the Bible is literal inerrant Word
of God and there's another 47 who
believe that it's inspired by God
so the vast majority of Americans are at
least religious to that extent and and a
quarter of Americans are religious
fundamentalist according to Matthew Dowd
and yet we don't see Christians going
around and raiding games raping and
looting and blowing people up but this
is the stupidity of the media that's
looking for moral equivalence wherever
it can find it okay so let's do some of
the mailbag now all right eNOS has been
quick top five Halloween October movies
though okay so Halloween movie so I have
to admit I'm not a scary movie fan scary
movies are not my thing they tend to be
kind of off-putting to me if I if I were
forced into it I would say The Shining
is in my top five mmm I'm not a huge
psycho fan and the reason being that the
first two-thirds of it is great then
though the ending is so weird like last
ten minutes of it is so men didn't die
I'm having a hard time coming up with
with movies that I think are really
scary that are good that are not sci-fi
like for example I really like 10
Cloverfield Lane but I don't think that
counts as a horror movie even though
maybe it should but it's sort of a quasi
horror film
I like Lockbox movies the ones where
it's like the two people in the clinic
closed space and they sort of have to
deal with it but that's but not my
favorite thing so instead of answering
your question I'm going to answer a
question I'm making up on my own because
it occurred on Twitter yesterday and
that was top 5 action movies so I
separate action from adventure which is
why my list is a little bit different
from other people's lists so I don't
include movies like Indiana Jones and my
top 5 action movies because it's more of
an adventure movie adventure to me is
characterized by going to kind of exotic
places and engaging in period combat you
know like like Adventures of Robin Hood
but my top 5 action films are and let me
see if I can find the list that I made
if my list was die hard Terminator 2 the
fugitive the Bourne Identity and taken
so taken makes a list I know a lot of
people disagree with this there are
there are some other action movies that
I think are close up on the list I'm
particularly like some people gladiator
gladiators not an action movie to make
it's it's it's a it's a historical epic
it's not not really as much for an
action film for me it's no one fires
into an automatic weapon at any point in
the film then
oh then it's probably not an action
movie unless there are bunch of great
action set-pieces like a train trying to
run you over like in the fugitive it's
amazing how the fugitive is sort of been
forgotten but it's so eminently
watchable if you're flipping around TV
and the fugitive is on then the chances
are that you're going to end up watching
at least fifteen minutes of it but
diehard obviously top of the West I
heart is just an amazingly good film the
script is so good the key to a great
film period is that the villain has to
be fantastic and each one of these films
the villain is is really good or at
least the the situation is really
compelling so diehard the villain is one
of the greatest villains in film history
Hans Gruber is one of the best villains
ever Terminator 2 Robert Patrick playing
the the kind of puddle of metal that can
morph in the t1000 it's just it's it's
spectacular the fugitive is great
performing comment we Jones won Best
Supporting Actor Oscar port Bourne
Identity has some of the great action
scenes in film history and taken I love
taken I got to admit I think taken is an
amazing action film taken is it's it's
become so iconic that now everybody is
that now everybody is um you know makes
up lines from it you know the I have a
particular set of skills that I mean
look it up should an entire new career
in for Liam Neeson being like this old
tough guy who beats people up Liam
Neeson also happens to be one of my
favorite actors so there's that like one
of the great tragedies of gangs of new
york is that they take him and murder
him in the first 15 minutes of the film
it's like I have to watch three hours of
Leonardo DiCaprio versus Daniel
day-lewis when I could have watched
three hours of Liam Neeson versus Daniel
day was when that a better film what if
they made it what if they made Leonardo
DiCaprio the we like his father like
reverse the casting and Liam Neeson
young Liam Neeson versus Daniel
day-lewis for the rest of that film so
much better like Liam Neeson just makes
stuff better dark man is not a good
movie but it's a good movie because Liam
Neeson is in it it's Liam Neeson is
awesome they have to stop killing him in
the first 10 minutes of every film
there's like a thousand films where Liam
Neeson gets killed in the first 15
minutes and stupid stop doing that
people it's annoying like even in
silence he's the best thing in silence
he's in silence for like ten minutes and
it's fantastic by the way good movie
silence I actually I think the best
Scorsese film in silence okay Erik says
hey Ben how much can you bench so I am I
know that sounds geeky I'm more of a
CrossFit guy than a benchpress guy
because I'm not looking to gain bulk I'm
will
long and lean I'm just a massive coiled
tension and muscle the last time I tried
to do any sort of benching I think I
topped out around like 215 so not huge
amounts of weight but I benched it I
think six times so I don't know what my
top my top bench is but I'm not like I'm
not a bodybuilder or weight lifter I can
say that I can pump out 100 pushups
pretty easily and I can pump out 30
pull-ups pretty easily you know that all
the sort of active stuff that I've
flipped lots of tires and hit things
with with hammers and such and I can do
the and I'm very proud of this I can do
the Navy the American Ninja Warrior
thing where they have like the pegboard
where there's a board and they take the
pegs and they climb up the board using
the pegs I can do that as well so that's
kind of fun Alexandra says hey Ben what
is a good non-religious argument against
issues like euthanasia and assisted
suicide thing so I've told people this
is an issue where I am split when it
comes to the legality of euthanasia and
assisted suicide what I have a problem
with regards euthanasia and assisted
suicide is making doctors into modes of
death dispensation where do you draw the
line right so some people say okay well
for terminal patients euthanasia that's
the strongest case but just like
abortion that's like using rape and
incest to justify the whole thing what
about somebody who just has depression
right now I think into the statistics
are like one in 200 people in the
Netherlands is put to death through
euthanasia
I don't want doctors to be trained in
in-depth you actually get a market for
that then right you get a market in
doctors who dispense death at the lowest
available prescription rate and I think
that a society that forwards dealing in
death is is likely to start taking life
less seriously plus you could have a lot
of malfeasance I mean you could see a
situation in which family members are
pressuring an older member of the family
to just get it over with that they can
take the inheritance or somebody has
Alzheimer's and the family just decides
okay put them out of their misery I
think it's it's a bit of a slippery
slope euthanasia that's that's the
secular argument a Dakota says does the
Bill of Rights apply to the states if so
are any of California's new gun laws in
violation of the Second Amendment so
great question the Bill of Rights
originally did not apply to the States
it is only about the federal government
because it is a federal document over
the course of time the Supreme Court
gradually did what they called the
incorporation doctrine
we're in order to apply a lot of the
elements of the of the Constitution to
southern states particularly that we're
violating those provisions of the
Constitution with regard to their black
top population the the Supreme Court
started using the 5th and 14th
amendments the due process clause to try
and suggest that states were bound by
the Due Process Clause and the Equal
Protection Clause to enforce all of the
other elements of the Constitution that
seems bad constitutional law to me the
First Amendment actually does not apply
I mean person in the wording of the
First Amendment obviously doesn't apply
to the states right says Congress shall
make no law abridging freedom of speech
right Congress Congress a federal
institution I don't know how you apply
that to the states but now that's been
legally applied to the states
it applies so if you were to apply the
Second Amendment to the the people of
California then yes California's gun
laws almost universally violate the
Second Amendment to the Constitution
Tyler says hey Ben do you think
legalizing medical marijuana on the
federal level would help combat the
opioid epidemic also do you think Big
Pharma would lobby against this so Tyler
I haven't seen evidence that the that
marijuana present in particular states
has lowered effects of the opioid
epidemic so if you could show me
evidence of that then I'd be all in
favor of that I'm in favor of legalizing
marijuana on the federal level anyway
because I don't think the federal
government has done a good job of
policing it what that said I think that
it is it is worth noting that the high
apparently that you get from marijuana
is not even close to the high that you
get from opioids and opioids are
significantly more addictive the
evidence on marijuana addictiveness is
mixed at best the evidence on opioid
addictiveness is extraordinarily strong
maybe next week we'll talk a little bit
more more about President Trump's
decision to to declare the opioid
epidemic a national emergency I'm not
sure what the federal government can do
here the bottom line with the opioid
epidemic is spreading from two
particular sources one influx of heroin
from down south across the Mexican
border to the the over-prescription of
drugs like vicodin and oxycontin that
started in the in the 1990s and 2000 and
so people would have an injury and then
they would go get oxycontin they'd be
basically using what is a soft form of
heroin and then they would go out and
seek a further high actually one of the
things the federal government did was
exacerbate this because people who are
on Medicaid could go
a bottle of pills that was worth like a
thousand dollars about Tico Don buy it
for $3 and then sell it on the open
market in order to make some money while
at the same time addicting themselves
there's a lot to talk about with regard
to the opioid epidemic but you know what
it is it is a several pronged problem
one is enforcement of the border two is
we need to ensure that doctors stopped
over prescribing this medication and
three there's a national spiritual
problem among young Americans right now
or searching for meaning and filling it
with drugs and that's a serious issue
kali says if you were to ask a question
for the mail bag what would it be well
it would be been why don't they double
your salary that would probably be and
my answer would be I don't know I'm the
boss I should do that shouldn't I
Tyler says hey Ben I don't like sports I
don't drink I'm 22 how on earth am I
supposed to have a social life I find it
hard to have friends and most of my
peers have totally different priorities
I'm generally a social guy and by no
means an introvert but I have almost no
interest in what most people my age care
about I imagine this is a rather common
problem with young conservatives how
would you advise people like me deal
with the Salama so you know I think that
listen when I was in college I was not
world's most social animal when I was in
law school I also don't drink not out of
principle because I'll have a drink
every so often but because as some bad
acid reflux so it doesn't doesn't do it
does the job on me but a number I do I
sports I can talk about that but I think
that there's always America is a huge
place with lots of people live there
with varying interests obviously we have
a huge audience here at the Ben Shapiro
show and that means there are lots of
people who think like you if you listen
to the show and want to talk about
issues like this because they spend time
every day listening to this content if
you're interested in politics politics
is a conversation starter and you should
be able to find people who are willing
to talk about deep issues by the way
when you're dating that is the stuff
that you should talk about are the deep
issues my you know my wife our friends
before our first date was legitimately
three our conversation about free will
and determinism not joking we've married
now for almost 10 years we have two
beautiful children and we are an
extraordinarily happy couple Jackson
says hey Ben the Jewish faith teach that
some sins are worse than others also
does it teach that they're unforgivable
sin so Judaism says that some sins are
more serious than others obviously
there's a different level of punishment
for different levels of sins murder is a
more serious crime than eating not
kosher for example and I think any
religion that suggests that all sins are
equally as egregious
is not a religion worth listening to
because obviously that's not true
Judaism does say that you can't impute
to God your own justification for
particular sins so it's up to God to
decide which ones are more severe but
yes there are levels of severity when it
comes to sin as evidenced by the
different punishments um you can bring a
sacrifice for some you die for right as
far as unforgivable sins so I believe
that they say the unforgivable sins in
Judaism and forgive me if I get this
wrong I'm sure other Orthodox Jews will
write me if I do
but the unforgivable sins in the sense
that you must pay for them are adultery
idolatry and murder I believe are the
three Biggie's so if you do those three
any of those three then those are
essentially unforgivable Jackson says
what's your beef with Michael Knowles I
don't have a beef with Michael Knowles I
my big four with Michael Moses where is
the beef I mean that's my peoples
Michael Knowles you wrote an empty book
and sold 120,000 copies but that's my
beef with Michael Knowles and come on
come on I mean Chris says I did not wait
for marriage I'm not proud of this I'm
at the point in my life where I want to
get married what is the best way to
address my pass with my girlfriend
possible fiance well first of all I mean
I think that you should just say that I
think that you should say exactly what
you say here you didn't wait for
marriage you wish that you had you want
to bring up your children's that they do
that and I think repentance is a
wonderful thing I think that you
realizing that you made a mistake and
that you wish you hadn't
that's okay you know we all make
mistakes in life you know being honest
about your past and suggesting that
you've gotten beyond it is the best way
for your potential spouse to know that
you're capable of that sort of thing
which is really important Genesis Ben
what is your honest take on stay-at-home
moms do you leave college-educated women
who choose this lifestyle have wasted
their education thank you no I don't
think that they've wasted their
education at all I think that whatever
choice you make to be at home with your
kids is a good choice and the balance
that you choose to make between career
and being at home is your choice I think
that you know women who choose not to be
at home with their kids at all have a
serious problem that's why one of the
reasons my wife is working the way she's
working is because she is hoping that
when she's done she's able to create a
much better work/life balance than if
she didn't go through a couple of years
of of poop to get to the to the roses
and as my grandmother used to say
sometimes you have to walk through the
poop to get to the roses and the manure
to get to the roses and I think that's
what a lot of you know the educational
process is all about but no I think that
you know stay-at-home moms are doing
something that is is vital I mean you
can see that there
has been a tremendous impact on children
who don't have parents around as much
thanks to things like divorce there's
not a rip on working women but everybody
has to balance out how much time is
necessary with your kids and how much
time is necessary in the workplace and
there's this idea that you can have it
all no you can't have it all you can
have a lot of most things and this is
not a case against women in the
workplace either okay a couple of more
questions and then we'll dump Callie
says with Google and the memo being a
hot topic in the news this week I was
wondering what is your belief the rule
should or should not play if a business
is discriminating and hiring and/or
paying employees my belief is that the
government should pay no role in this
because if a business discriminate in
hiring then they are losing money
because the idea is of discrimination
inherently is that you're going to avoid
hiring the best person for a particular
job and you're going to hire instead
somebody else which means somebody else
is going to hire the best person to make
more money than you and if you don't pay
employees that well then you're going to
be able to then that person can go
across the street free markets tend to
get rid of discrimination not for
everybody but over the course of time
I'm going to try and read this backwards
oh no that's it okay so okay so so
Malthus is going to fix this because
otherwise I'm literally reading a email
live backwards and upside down okay it's
loading
there we go Bunbury you're fond of
saying students shouldn't sacrifice
their grades to make their argument for
conservatism after the Google memo is
clear not even safe after school what
can we do well again I think that there
is there's something to be said for the
Google memo guy we had on yesterday just
in the sense that he has now raised the
raise the consciousness of the country
with regard to the sort of
discrimination that's happening at
Google so that's a calculated decision
you have to decide whether you think
you're going to do the most good by
fighting the power where you stand or by
you know staying in the closet is
conservative until you have more power
and I think that that changed the
situation by situation but I don't think
that it's worthwhile always granting a
baton to the bad guys in order to make a
point because sometimes that point does
not go over or is worthless
okay so we will be back here next week
with all the latest news thanks so much
for everything that you do for the show
we really appreciate it again we are the
number two podcast in America after
Oprah and and if we continue to grow
then we will overtake Oprah Oprah the
lenda s and and we will
eventually take that top slide on iTunes
which would be pretty awesome so we will
see you next week have a wonderful
weekend I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
[Music]